ونشرت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه صورا لما
قالت انها عمليه اطلاق صواريخ وانطلاق
طائرات من حاملات طائرات امريكيه ضد اهداف
لجماعه انصار الله دون ان تحدد توقيت هذه
العمليات معنا من صنعاء مراسل الجزيره
محمد العطاب محمد هل توفرت لديك المزيد من
تفاصيل حول هذه الهجمات
نعم نحن نتحدث الان عن 15 غاره شنها
التحالف البريطاني الامريكي في على مناطقه
في الحديده وفي صعدا نتحدث في صعدا انه شن
ما يقارب ثمان غارات على منطقه راس عيس
وهي منطقه تقع بالقرب من الساحل البحر
الاحمر وهي شمال مدينه الحديده وايض ايضا
شن ما يقارب ثلاث غارات على مناطق في
الزيديه وهي تقع شمال راس عيسى وهي مناطق
ايضا زراعيه ومنها مناطق تطل على البحر
الاحمر وكذلك شن عده غارات على منطقه
الحوك وهي تقع بالقرب من داخل مدينه
الحديده و وهي احدى حارات مدينه الحديده
وايضا شن على في صعده على منطقه باقم
وشرقي صعده
ولا تمر غاره من غارات امريكا ودون ان تشن
الغارات على شرقيه صعده لا نعلم ما هي
الاهداف هناك وكما شن
ايضا في البارحه اكثر من 48
غاره حسب تاكيد المصدر المتحدث الناطق
باسم جماعه انصار الله واكد العميد يحيى
سريع بان تلك الغارات كان النصيب الاسد
وهو وهي
مدينتي صنعاء وتعز حيث صنعاء تعز نالت
اكثر من 11 غاره في منطقه واحده وهي
استهداف لشبكات ااتصالات وهنا في صنعاء
كانت الغارات مركزه على جبلي النهدين
وعطال هذه الليله لم تشهد الغارات في
كثافتها م مثل ما كانت البارحه فقط في قبل
ساعتين كذا كانت هناك هذه الغارات حدود 15
غاره وهي حسب تصريحات المتحدثين من قبل
الاداره الامريكيه او الجيش الامريكي
بانهم يقيمون في كل
مرحله عملياتهم وما وما هو يمكن ان يصل
الى اهدافهم وهي تقوي قدرات جماعه انصار
الله فيما اكد المتحدث العسكري باسم جماعه
انصار الله بان تلك العمليات لن تؤثر في
مسيرتهم وعملياتهم التي يقولون بانهم
مصلون فيها حتى يرفع الحصار على غزه
وينتهي العدوان وقالوا بان ذلك لن يثنيهم
ومطالبين ايضا من المجتمع الدولي ومن
الامم المتحده على الاستمرار في الضغط على
اسرائيل لانهاء عدوانها ورفع
حصارها محمد لنفهم منك اكثر نتحدث الان
اذا عن 11 غاره في الحديده وصعده كذلك هل
عرفت طبيعه المواقع المستهدفه
اليوم عندما نتحدث عن منطقه راس عيسى هي
منطقه من الس كانت الاستقبال واستيراد
كانت ايضا لتصدير النفط اليمني ولكن توقفت
خلال فتره الحرب فلم يعد هناك تصدير للنفط
اليمني وكانت هي المنطقه الرئيسيه لتصدير
النفط والان اصبحت من ضمن المناطق التي
يستقبل فيها اليمنيون النفط من الخارج
الان اصبحت اليمن من الدول التي تستورد
النفط والغاز بعد ان كانت تصدرهما نتحدث
عن هذه المنطقه هي منطقه نفطيه وايضا
منطقه لانتاج الكهرباء بالقرب منها تقع
اهم شركات انتاج الكهرباء التي تغذي مدينه
الحديده وايضا
هناك اماكن
ل لاستخراج الملح واماكن اخرى لكن لا
نستطيع ان نحدد ان هناك اهداف عسكريه
بالضبط لكن حسب قراءات الامريكيين انهم
يعتقدون بان تلك المناطق تستخدم لاتراك
المسيرات او المص الصواريخ وقد استهدفت
ايضا مناطق بال بالقرب من من منها من
بالقرب او بالقرب من هذه المنطقه البارحه
استهدفت
جزير ينطلق
منها على المسيرات
لكن وفيما يخص
صعده كل مره تستهدف مناطق شرقيه صعده وهي
منطقه الجبليه لا نستطيع ان نؤكد ما هي
الاهداف التي تم استهدافها فيقول الحوثيون
بان هذه المناطق اصبحت مناطق خاليه فقد
استهدفت في السابق ولم يعد هناك ما يستهدف
ويؤكد ايضا الخبراء عسكريون بان جماعه
انصر يعملون بطريقه حرب الجوريلا وهي حرب
العصابات التي تعتمد على الجماعات الصغيره
وايضا على المعدات الصغيره التي لا تتطلب
اخفائها او تحريكها معدات ثقيله او اشياء
صعبه فاخفاها امر سهل وتحريكها امر سهل
بالنسبه لديهم فيما امريكا وهي من
وبريطانيا وهي من الدول التي تعتمد على
الحرب التقليديه كل ما تحتاجه من معدات
عسكريه ثقيله والجيوش ثقيله تتطلب لقنها
وحركتها واخفائها تتطلب امور صعبه جدا
وهذا هو المقارنه التي يؤكد العسكريون بان
هذه المقارنه هي تشكل الفارقه التي يمكن
ان يحقق النصر او الفشل في هذه العمليات
التي تشن على جماعه انصار الله ا محمد
لنستمع معك الكثير او المزيد من المعطيات
هل هذه الجمات اليوم هل كانت متزامنه
نتحدث عن 11
غاره وبالمقارنة
على وتيره اقل من الغارات وايضا وتيره اقل
من الاماكن التي استهدفت نتحدث فقط على
استهداف ما
يقارب سبع الى سبع مناطق او خمس مناطق
مقارنه بالبارحه كانت المناطق او المواقع
التي استدلت اكثر ف حسب الخبراء بان هناك
تقييم قب من قبل الامريكيون بانهم يحققون
نجاحات وانهم يستطيعون ان يقووا او يضعفوا
قدرات جماعه انصار الله لكن في العمليات
السابقه وما حصل في العمليات السابقه كان
قد اكد الجيش الامريكي بانه استطاع ان
يحدث ضعفا محددا في جماعه انصار الله في
ناحيه قدراتهم با اطلاق الصواريخ او
المسيرات لكن ما
يؤكده قاده الجماعه بانه خاصه زعيم
الجماعه زعيم الجماعه عبد الملكي بدر
الدين الحوثي بانه خلال فقط عمليات التي
شنت على على جماعتهم في مناطق عده
استطاعوا ان ان يصنعوا صاروخا استخدموه في
ضرب البارج البحريه وايضا استهداف السفينه
البريطانيه السفينه الشحن البريطانيه
لواندا والتي ظلت تحترق لليلتين حسب
تاكيده وايضا استطاع استطاع حسب تاكيد
المتحدث العسكري بسب يستهدف البارجه
البحريه الامريكيه فهم يؤكدون كل ما حصلت
لهم من ضربات ومن غارات من قبل التحالف
البريطاني الامريكي فانهم يقول ينهضون
اقوى ويستطيعون ان يستمرون في عملياتهم
لكن الان ما حصل من غارات البارحه 48 غاره
وهذه الليله ما يقارب خ 15 غاره لم لم يكن
هناك حتى الان اي رده فعل من قبل جماعه
الانصاري ولكن حسب المتحدث العسكري لجماعه
الانصار الله يؤكد بان تلك الغارات التي
شرت عليهم لن تمر حسب كلامه دون عقاب ارجو
ان تبقى معنا محمد تنضم الينا الان بيسان
او بكويك مراسلاتنا مراسلاتنا من واشنطن
سان القياده الوسطى الامريكيه نشرت صور
لما قالت انها عمليه اطلاق صواريخ وانطلاق
طائرات من حامله حاملات طائرات امريكيه
دون ان تحدد التوقيت لا ندري ان كان الامر
يتعلق بهذه الهجمات ام لا او اذا كان هناك
اي موقف او تصريح صدر من واشنطن بخصوص هذه
العمليات حتى اللحظه وسيله ما زلنا ب ظار
تاكيد رسمي هنا من واشنطن او من القياده
المركزيه بان هذه الغارات هي بالفعل
مرتبطه ب ما تم نشره من صور حول اطلاق
صواريخ من ثلاث حاملات طائرات هي
ريفليزي
وطبعا يعني ان كان ما يحدث الان هو
بالفعل يعني حمله عسكريه او غارات امريكيه
جديده فهي تاتي بعد اقل من 24 ساعه من
حمله اخرى كانت قد شنتها الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا بالامس استهدفت
36 هدفا
و13 موقعا وطبعا تاتي بعد الاستهدافات
والضربات العسكريه والرد الامريكي اي في
العراق وسوريا يوم الجمعه ردا على مقتل
الجنود الامريكيين الثلاثه طبعا هذه
الاستهدافات من قبل الولايات المتحده نعم
تاتي ضمن هذا الرد الامريكي الذي كانت قد
وعدت به بعد مقتل الجنود الامريكيين
الثلاثه ولكن كان ه هناك ردود امريكيه
وضربات امريكيه تستهدف مواقع تابعه
للحوثيين على مدار الشهرين الماضيين
تقريبا بعد استهدافات الحوثيين لسفن
للملاحه والشحن في البحر الاحمر وسمعنا
اليوم من مستشار الرئيس بايدن للامن
القومي يعني يتحدث عن هذه الردود
الامريكيه بان اي استهداف للامريكيين
سيكون هناك رد ان حمايه الامن البحري طبعا
وهذا الامر والتجاره العالميه
وخطوط الامدادات المياه والتجاره وخطوط
الشحن العالميه امر توليه الولايات
المتحده اهميه كبرى وقد انشا التحالف هو
حراس الازدهار من اجل يعني
حمايه هذه الخطوط خطوط الشحن وطبعا بالامس
في بيان
القياده المركزيه حين صدر بالضربات
العسكريه كانت قد قالت ان هذه الضربات او
تلك الضربات التي حدثت بالامس هي حقيقه
منفصله عن اعمال
تامين خطوط الشحن وال وخطوط طبعا
امدادات المياه وخطوط المياه في البحر
الاحمر
وحريه الملاحه وان الهدف من استهداف
الحوثيين وفق ما يصدر من تصريحات من
مسؤولين امريكيين هو اضعاف قدراتهم لاطلاق
اي صواريخ او او القيام باي عمليات تستهدف
عمليات الشحن او تعطيل عمليات
الشحن البحري ويعني الولايات المتحده تصر
وسمعنا الكلام ذلك اليوم من جيك سليفن
حقيقه ان نعم قد يكون للحرب على غزه وفق
تصريح سلفن علاقه بما يقوم به الحوثيون
ولكنهم يستهدفون ايضا صفنا حسب قوله لا لا
علاقه لها باسرائيل وهي من دول اخرى طبعا
العمليه التي حدثت في الامس كانت الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا قد شنتها وبدعم من ست
دول حليفه اخرى الان ما زلنا طبعا ننتظر
التاكيد بان هذه بالفعل يعني استهدافات
وغارات امريكيه اخرى تسته يعني ضد
الحوثيين بالامس العمليه استهدفت مخازن
لتخزين السلاح
والصواريخ
وال المسيرات وما الى ذلك لذا ننتظر اي
تفصيل ان كانت طبعا التاكيد بدايه وان
كانت هذه الع العمليه ايضا ما هي الاهداف
التي كانت مرجوه من هذه العمليه ان كانت
بالفعل هي استهدافات وغارات امريكيه وسيره
وطبعا في انت اذار التاكيد الرسمي من
واشنطن وتحديد
الاهداف التي تم استهدافها اليوم اعود
اليك محمد العطاب هذه العمليه تقول واشنطن
هي لاضعاف قدرات جماعه انصار ال انت تقول
حتى الان لم يصدر موقف رسمي ل من الجماعه
بهذا الخصوص لكن لنستذكر معا موقف الجماعه
بهذا الخصوص وهي التي تصر على الاستمرار
على
نهجها نعم لدينا تصريح جاء قبل ساعات من
قبل الناطق الرسمي باسم جماعه انصار الله
وهو المتحدث محمد عبد السلام وقال بان
العمليات التي تشنها امريكا لن تستطيع ان
تضعف من قدراتهم ب ت يؤكد ويجزم على ذلك
ويؤكد بان تلك القدرات او ما استطاعوا ان
يصلوا اليه من من امكانيات عسكريه قالوا
ان استطاع استطاع ان يصلوا عليه في فترات
قاسيه من وتحت حرب مستمر فيؤكد بان الحرب
التي تخاض ضدهم او تشن ضدهم ستجعلهم اقوى
حسب تعبيره في هذا في هذا التصريح وايضا
يؤكد بان ما تقوم به امريكا من وبريطانيا
من عمليات حتى في العراق او في مناطق اخرى
من من العالم العربي فانها تشكل ما وصفه
تزيد من حده الغضب او السخط الشعبي العارم
في المنطقه العربيه حسب توصيفه بانه س
ستجعل من
تواجد الامريكي والبريطاني في المنطقه من
الامر الصعب جدا واكد بان بان تلك الغارات
او العمليات التي تشن ضدهم لن لن لن
تثنيهم عن عن موقفهم المبدئي والاخلاقي
والديني بجانب ا اهالي غزه فهم يؤكدون بان
عملياتهم شنت او بدا ب بداوا بها من اجل
ان يضغطوا على اسرائيل وان يضغطوا على
المجتمع الدولي لتشكيل ضغط او لوبي من
الضغط حتى ينتهي العدوان او ما يصفونه
بجرائم الحرب الاباده التي تشن ضد اهالي
غزه ف فاكثر من ما يقارب 12 يوما لازالت
مستمره وكل يوم يشهد استمرارا لمزيد من
الجرائم ومزيد من الضحايا في في منطقتنا
تتجاوز 36 في 36 م مربع وبداخلها اكبر
كثافه سكانيه في العالم فهذه الماساه هي
تشكل الضغط الشعبي فجمعه الصاله يؤكدون
بان ما يقوم به ايضا هو تحت ضغط شعبي يخرج
كل اسبوع وكل يوم المئات الالاف من
اليمنيين يدفعون الى اتجاه المزيد من
الضغط والمزيد من الضربات حتى تنتهي
اسرائيل عن ما تقوم به في في غزه
فذلك يعتبر حسب قولهم موقفا مبدئيا
وانسانيا واخلاقيا ودينا تجاه اخوانهم في
غزه شكرا جزيلا لك محمد العطاب مراسلنا من
صنعاء كما اشكر كذلك مراسلتنا من واشنطن
بان ابو كويك